The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons License.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
NEEMA NASSIR: So good
afternoon, everyone.
Today, we are going to continue
the discussion regarding
short-range planning
for transit agencies.
And if you do not have
the set of slides,
the handout from last week,
there are extra copies here.
Please, you can take from here.
OK.
Thanks.
So last week we--
last Thursday, we talked
about the basic concepts
in the practice of
short-range transit planning,
the level of service guidelines
and performance measures that
could actually be
defined and used
for the practice,
particularly related
to excess distances,
services span, maximum load,
convenience, and
comfort measures.
Today, we will talk
a little bit more
about guidelines and standards
related to reliability,
and then we will talk about
some of the useful performance
measures that could be
defined and measured
for transit service.
And then we will talk
about the actual procedure
of short-range planning for some
of the agencies from which we
have some examples.
And then we will talk about
some of the caveats that
could actually be
identified for those.
So let's start with guidelines
and with the standards related
to reliability first.
So in terms of reliability, as
we briefly discussed last week,
most agencies have
formal procedures
for monitoring service delivery
focusing on time performance.
The on-time
performance is usually
considered to be zero minutes
early and up to five minutes
late.
As we discussed, early arrivals
is not considered on-time.
That could be because early
departures basically are not
considered on-time because
early departures could actually
have a more negative
impact on travel time.
And the other possible
reason is that it's probably
early departures
are easier to avoid.
When you compare later
arrivals or later departures,
possible reasons
that could actually
contribute to a
late arrival could
be the vehicle getting stuck
in traffic, congestion,
or due to high load and high
dwell times, which is usually
difficult to avoid.
But when it comes to early
arrivals and early departures,
the driver could actually slow
down in the upstream segments
to make sure that the
arrival is kind of on time.
So about 2/3 of agencies--
there are different thresholds
that are defined in terms
of acceptable thresholds
for the percentage of arrivals
within this tolerance interval
from zero to five minutes late.
However, the usual practice
is that about 2/3 of agencies
report on rush hour, on-time
performances of 90% and above.
But in practice, this threshold
ranges between 80%, 85%,
up to 90%, 98%, depending
on the mode of the service
and depending on the situation,
how the congestion level is,
how the load in the network
is, if there is right of way,
like separated right of way for
that transit service or not.
So it is written somehow
as specific to the system,
but 90% is basically the
threshold that 2/3 of agencies
basically accept.
Most agencies also keep
track and keep route level
information on
passenger complaints
that could relate to
on-time or late arrivals.
It could relate also
to denial to board
or to the crowding situation.
They would also keep
track and keep information
on missed trips and
accidents and interruptions
and disruptions, basically.
So when it comes to
reliability, there
is a need to explain this.
I briefly mentioned
this last week,
that the services,
the transit service
is basically classified
into two types.
One is walk-up service, which
is related to higher frequency
service that is
usually schedule-free
and/or headway-based.
Typically with a service
that is with headway
less than 10 minutes or some
say less than 15 minutes,
it's considered to
be walk-up service.
For example, the T service
in the central area of Boston
would be considered
a walk-up service.
BRT systems are
also, some of them
are schedule-free and
could be considered walk-up
or basically, headway-based.
Performance measures
that are related
to reliability for walk-up
service is based on headway,
and it basically measures
the regularity of headways.
As opposed to service, which
is scheduled that's basically
based on published timetables
and published schedule
and delivered based on
that, basically that's
the service that is
usually for longer headway.
Headway is longer than 10
minutes, 10, 15 minutes.
And the performance measure
related to this service
is usually being done
or being measured
based on punctuality of
service, being late or early.
So again, a trip is
considered on time
at each time point
along the route
and on the performance
window, basically.
So usually, transit
agencies, for each route
they define certain
time points, which
could be major stops or
stations but usually, they
are less frequent.
I mean every three
or four stops,
there could be one
time point that you
measure the on-time arrivals and
on-time departures from there.
You may have noticed, if
you're on a certain bus,
this is my personal
experience, when I
lived in Brisbane in Australia.
There were some routes
that at some time when
you see that the bus is early,
the driver could actually
really slow down
before certain points,
and you could tell where
exactly the time point is
that the driver is
trying to basically make
an on-time arrival
to those time points.
So arrivals are
measured at these time
points along the route.
Right.
So what are the actual
standards and actual tolerance
or thresholds that agencies
consider for service
reliability measures?
One example is here from MBTA.
MBTA, actually for
walk-up service,
which is the case for
most of the T service,
it allows basically
actual headway
of up to 1.5 times
the scheduled headway
at origins and at time points.
And then at
destinations, it also
defines another measure that
deals with the schedule's
running time.
So basically,
there are two hooks
that it kind of measures
the service based on those.
One is the regularity
of service.
It doesn't allow or it
wants to measure cases
where headway is longer than
expected, like 1.5 times
the scheduled headway.
And the other constraint is
that the actual running time
is between 0.8 and 1.2 of
the scheduled running time.
So when it comes
to actual headway,
you can see that there
is no lower bound
to the actual headway.
Does anyone have any comments
why there is no actual lower
bound here?
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: Lower than
scheduled headway just means
that there's more service.
And if that leaves a
gap somewhere else,
then that would be
record-- that would
count for over the schedule.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
Yeah.
Given that the number of trips
are constant during the day,
if you guarantee that there
is a maximum headway, then
on the other hand,
you can kind of
guarantee that headway
is not too short there.
However, when it comes
to scheduled service,
then there is constraints on
early and late departures,
basically.
So at origins, what MBTA
considers, at origin terminus,
considers on-time departures
between zero and three
minutes, zero minutes early
and three minutes late.
And then at time
points, it allows up
to seven minutes late.
Does anyone have any comments
about the difference?
Why does it allow
less late departures
at the origin terminus?
AUDIENCE: Give us control
at the intermediary terminus
[INAUDIBLE] at the terminal.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah.
That could be the case.
or to put it the other
way, transit agencies,
when they schedule these
trips and they schedule
these vehicles, they
allow a recovery time
between the end of one trip and
the beginning of the next trip.
And that actually
is there to kind
of help with
punctuality of service,
and therefore, it does allow
less tolerance on delay
at the beginning.
But when it goes
along the route, when
bus goes along the
route, it kind of
gets out of control
as you mentioned.
There are not really good
ways and good leverages
to allow buffer to
the running time.
And then at the
destination, it's basically,
MBTA allows up to
three minutes early
and five minutes late
it should be obvious
why it allows early arrivals
to destination because it's
the last stop, and we don't need
to worry about arriving early
to the final destination.
At the route level, there
is one other guideline
that, at the route level, 75%
of time points must be on time.
So although for
the overall system,
the threshold here was in
the range of 90% or 95%,
or between 80%, 85%, and 95%.
But at route level,
when you're looking
at the on-time arrivals,
it has to be larger
than 75% of the time.
So what will happen
if it doesn't--
a certain route doesn't
meet this standard?
Is there any thoughts?
Oh, please.
AUDIENCE: You could shift
the schedule for that segment
and republish it and add extra--
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah.
So you can increase,
basically, the running time
and make sure that you adjust
the schedule in a way that
can be delivered punctually.
So that's what's
explained in this slide.
So if you observe in some of the
routes the performance in terms
of punctuality is poor,
then you can take a look
at the historical data and
historical performances
in terms of running time,
revise the running time
from terminus to terminus
and that will actually,
you can basically revise that to
be a mean of this distribution,
assuming that the travel
times, the running times
are distributed normally.
And go ahead, please.
AUDIENCE: I mean, if it's
only a 5% probability
that this will happen
but it happens actually
a lot more than that.
It's probably a result
of another factor,
like drivers or vehicles
or traffic or [INAUDIBLE]
constructions [INAUDIBLE].
NEEMA NASSIR: Well,
that's a good point, yeah.
So there may be,
for example, you
know when there is shared right
of way with background traffic,
there's a lot of indeterminacy
in terms of travel time,
especially if the
roadway is congested,
and that could be one possible
result for unreliability
of running time.
One possible thing that could
be done is like dedicated lanes
to the transit
and kind of trying
to improve the performance
and match the schedule.
So that could be one other way.
But what I mentioned was that if
this is the last thing that we
can do and that we
cannot basically improve
the reliability of arrivals, we
may actually allow a little bit
of buffer to the travel time.
And that's not only by extending
the running time to a job
that we can observe,
but also, you
can adjust the recovery
time between end
of one trip to the next trip
to the chosen amount that
makes sure that a certain
confidence can actually
be gained in terms of on-time
performance of next trip.
In terms of the actual
objective that TransLink
has in place for
reliability, again depending
on different modes,
TransLink defines
different acceptance thresholds
for given on-time definitions.
And on-time definitions
could actually
vary as well as a level of
compliance or the acceptance
threshold.
So is there any
questions about this?
Any comments?
So there are some more
detail measures and event
measures for transit service.
It comes to variables that
are related to transit service
supply and demand side.
Quantities actually
can be classified
into three different
groups, the quantities that
are related to
the service input,
quantities related
to service output,
and quantities related
to service consumption.
So service input is
basically the resources
that the transit agency is
using to produce the service.
Service output is basically
measuring the produced service.
And service consumption
is how this service
is being consumed and
being appreciated and being
used by the public.
So different measures
can be defined
to measure the performance
of transit system
based on these quantities.
For example, you can
look at only the vertices
of this triangle, like what is
the amount of labor, including
drivers and maintenance?
What is the capital cost of
the fleet and infrastructure?
What is the fuel
consumption in the system?
Or, on the other hand, you can
look at the service outputs.
It would be like a
measure of the service
in terms of how much
service the system actually
is producing in terms of vehicle
hours or revenue hours, vehicle
miles or revenue hours, capacity
miles and service reliability.
And then consumption
of service, that
is dealing with
number of passengers,
passenger miles, operating
revenue, and operating safety.
But you can go one level up
with playing with these measures
and compute, for example, the
ratios of these quantities.
So each one of these
edges basically
are dealing with the
ratio of one quantity
at one vertex as opposed to over
the quantity of the other one.
For example, what
we are basically--
efficiency measures
are basically
dealing with how we
are doing in terms
of producing service as
given our available resources
or the consumed resources.
The service
effectiveness basically
deals with how we are doing
in terms of giving service
to public, moving public
and producing mobility
in the network over
the service that we
produce, how our service
is appreciated and used
and utilized.
For example, a service that is
poorly designed, for example,
like every five
minute trips overnight
from a suburb to another
suburb, it's a service,
and it has produced vehicle
hours and vehicle miles.
It has consumed resources.
However, it may
not be appreciated
because it's poorly designed.
So that's the kind of
the role of measures
that are related to
service effectiveness
to take care of quality of
design and quality of service,
basically.
So and one other comment
about this triangle
is that the cost
efficiency measures
kind of dealing with the
quality of the planning
on the operational side,
operational planning.
How the optimization and
how the tactical decisions
are made in terms of
producing the most service out
of the existing resources.
On the other hand,
the decisions that
are related to service
planning could actually
use measures that are related
to service effectiveness.
So in terms of
alternative measures,
like benefit and cost measures
that could be defined and used
for short-range
transit planning--
before we go into discussion
of benefits and cost
for transit system, there is one
thing that I need to mention.
What's happening
in transit system
is that they are usually not
run, as you know, for profit
and that's probably one
of the main differences
between the business model of
a transit system as compared
to other regular businesses,
where they make decisions
based on profit and based on the
revenue over or benefit of cost
or better benefit over cost.
What happens in
transit agencies is
that it can be thought as a type
of benefit over cost analysis
but the cost and benefit
is a little bit different.
The benefit is dealing with the
public service and the amount
of consumer surplus
or the social welfare
that you can produce, the
mobility that you can produce.
On the other hand, the
cost could actually
include the operating cost and
also could include the revenue.
It basically can be defined as
operating cost minus revenue.
So when it comes to the
financial unit of benefit
and cost, the financial
unit includes both the cost
and revenue.
And then when it
comes to benefit,
what's usually being used
as a measure of benefit
is the service that
is being delivered
in terms of the
social welfare measure
or the mobility that actually
is produced in the network.
So once we discuss some of
these alternative measures,
it may be a little more clear.
So one of the
measures that could
be defined and really easy
probably to define and measure
is the revenue.
Like, what's the
fare box revenue?
What's the total?
The advantage that
this measure would have
is that it's very relevant
to financial concerns.
It actually, another
advantage that it has
is that it's related
to willingness to pay
and it could be used as a
proxy of quality of service.
However, the disadvantage that
could be mentioned for revenue
as a benefit measure
is that it discounts
value of reduced fare trips,
discounted trips, concession
trips.
And it also has the disadvantage
that it favors higher income
passengers.
So if we want to look
a little bit more
closely at the nature
of transit service
and what should be considered
as a benefit measure,
we need to look at
the mobility and try
to measure the mobility that has
been produced for the citizen,
for the people living
in the network.
So we can count the
number of passengers
who have used the system
and the advantage of this
is that it reflects the
number of people who benefit
and it basically values
each passenger equally.
However, the
shortcoming of counting
only the number of
passengers is that it kind of
doesn't reflect trip length.
Not reflecting trip
length basically kind of
ignores an important component
in mobility, which deals
with access to opportunities.
Which the access to
opportunities definitely cannot
decrease with the
opportunities for mobility.
And then the other
shortcoming is
that it basically
reflects on link trips
and not journeys or link trips.
So you basically
double count passengers
who are making
transfers, although they
may be traveling
to one destination
and there's only one
opportunity at one destination
or that will be actually
one activity happening
at the destination.
So one way to improve this
is to measure passenger miles
as a better proxy of
mobility in the network.
It has the advantage that
it weights longer trips more
and it's the best reflection of
benefits related to mobility.
Sorry about this.
However, it's
hardest to measure.
Does anyone have any idea,
comments about why it's hardest
to measure?
Why is passenger miles in the
network hardest to measure?
AUDIENCE: A lot of systems
don't have an exit.
They only have an
entrance stile.
NEEMA NASSIR: Exactly.
So considering that we're
using the data for passenger,
like from fare card
systems, many systems
do not have the
requirements of tapping
when you're exiting the system.
So that's something
that is missing.
So it requires some
sort of inference
of highlighting our exit
locations to be able to measure
the length of trip.
However, and the
other disadvantage
is that it could find favor
higher income passengers.
So any comments about this?
AUDIENCE: That assumes the
high-income passengers,
that assumes higher income
people travel further.
It's not necessarily the case.
NEEMA NASSIR: Not
necessarily the case
but in systems where you have
distance-based fare structure,
and when you basically have
the entrance and exits recorded
and you charge people by the
length or number of zones
that they have traveled,
that could be actually
somehow favoring higher
income passengers
because it is reasonable to
assume that higher income
people are less
sensitive to the fare
and so their decisions
are basically
kind of regardless of fare.
So any comments?
OK.
So then on the cost
side, the measures that
are dealing with
cost, the net cost
is basically cost
of resources that
are used to generate the
service minus the revenue.
And it's usually most
directly constrained
because that's exactly
the amount of money
that you need to
secure for the service.
The budget actually goes
directly to the net cost.
So that's the advantage.
However, the disadvantage is
that it's hardest to estimate.
Any comments about why it
could be hardest to estimate as
compared to cost?
At least for designs, for the
service that is not already
in place, if you need
to estimate the revenue
and deduct that from cost
to generate net cost,
it would be a
challenging thing to do,
to come up with estimates of
demand and predict the revenue.
So that could be one
of the shortcomings
of net cost for designs.
However, it may not
be that difficult when
we are dealing with
the existing service
because revenue is
basically already recorded
by the fare box system.
And then cost could be
another measure less directly
constrained because actually,
we need to combine that
with the revenue
to realize what's
the net cost of the system?
Again, it could be
hard to estimate
but probably not as hard when
we compare it with net cost.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: What is net cost?
NEEMA NASSIR: Net cost is
basically cost of operation
minus the revenue from fares.
And the reason that
it's tricky to measure
is that the revenue side is
probably a little difficult
to predict.
So the next measure of cost
could be vehicle miles.
That basically deals with
the service that is produced.
It's easy to measure
because you know number
of trips that are delivered to
the system, and length of trips
are known.
So vehicle miles is probably
the easiest measure to compute.
But the disadvantage
is that they only
reflect 3% of the cost
and that's probably
the part that is correlated
with fuel and with depreciation
of the vehicles and
with maintenance.
And then it also
penalizes fast service,
not [AUDIO OUT] traveled
fast and on time
as opposed to the
model that is basically
delivered in congestion
and with long delays.
Another measure that is
probably a little bit more
closely reflecting our
cost is the vehicle hours.
And the vehicle miles
and vehicle hours
are basically the revenue
miles and the revenue hours.
What I mean by revenue,
that's basically the miles
that these buses
and these vehicles
have been in service from
the start of their trip
to the end of the trip.
There may be some trips,
like dead-ending trips,
that the vehicle can
should go empty from one
location to another
location to the next trip,
and those miles and
those vehicle hours
are not counted here.
So vehicle hours basically,
again, are easy to measure.
And the other advantage is that
it's related to more than 50%
of bus costs.
It basically correlates
with the fuel consumption
and with driving
and operating cost.
So one of the cost
effectiveness measures
that MBTA uses for their system
and for their decision making
is basically net cost
per each passenger that
is using the system.
And then they usually define
this on a route basis.
So the index I here could
be net cost per passenger
for each route, and then it
shouldn't exceed three times
the system-wide net
cost per passenger.
So this is basically going back
to the triangle that we had.
This is one of the measures that
is dealing with resources that
are used to the
number of passengers
that are using the
service, regardless
of what the service was.
So in terms of issues in
setting up a short-range transit
planning process, this slide
mentions some of these issues,
starting with the
roll-off budget
constraints in the process
this could actually
be related to before budget is
set and after budget is set.
Before budget is set,
there is some indeterminacy
in measuring the net
cost and basically
the budget that is requested in
the proposal for a new service
or for a change in the service.
What's similar to any other
proposal that is usually done
is that you try to find
the minimum possible budget
that you're requesting for
what you're trying to deliver
and that could be
a challenging task.
And then after
the budget is set,
given all the indeterminacy
that was involved in predicting
the budget, then it's the issue
of optimizing the resources
and optimizing the budget to
deliver and to gain the most
out of the existing resources.
The other issue with--
AUDIENCE: So in this
part of the process,
I wonder if it should
be advisable to leave
a margin of maneuver in respect
to budget constraints normally
you would have, even if you go
for the minimum possible to get
85%, 80%, out of that,
for political reasons
or whatever reason there is.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
So that could actually make
the situation a little easier
for people who are
involved in planning
and for the actual plans, right?
So what Ricardo is
mentioning is there may be
some buffers or some internal--
some buffers in the budget
and some flexibility
in the budget that
could actually
be allowed when you're
requesting the budget
and when you're
delivering the budget,
delivering the service
that could actually
take care of some of
the indeterminacy that
is involved in the
prediction of the budget
and prediction of the costs.
So the next, possibly
the next issue
that is involved in the
traditional or the existing
practice for short-range
transit planning
is that we kind of have a set
of standards and constraints
that gives us lower bounds on
some of the service measures.
However, these
constraints only give us
an idea of what's the
feasible solution space.
It doesn't really tell us
what's the optimal design
and how you can
basically optimize
the allocation of resources
to improve the ridership.
And that could
actually involve some
of the art of the designers
and the art of people
who are involved in
identifying opportunities
within the standards and within
the constraints and guidelines
to address the situation
and to gain the most
out of the allocated resources.
Then again, when it comes
to design of service,
there is also this issue
between the existing
service and proposals and
plans for additional service.
As I mentioned last week,
the design of service
is never from scratch.
There is always something
there for good reasons
and you may want to predict
the existing service
as much as possible
because people
are relying on the service.
They probably have formed
their travel habits and travel
attitudes based on
the existing service.
So changing these
services probably
need to be really careful
and thoughtful, basically.
However, when it comes to
addition of new service,
we may want to make sure
that the new service
kind of supports the
existing service effectively
and with all the overlaps
and all the misconnections
are identified in advance
and taken care of.
Issue that we will eventually
talk about it later
in another slide is that
some of existing practice
is dealing with short-range
transit planning decisions
dealing poorly
performing routes.
But the optimal
design is not always
dealing with changing the
ones that are only poor,
the only ones that
are poorly performing.
There may be some
changes that you
can do to well-performing routes
to improve the overall system
performance and the
network level performance.
So is there any
questions so far?
How am I doing on time?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Professor Nassir, does
the cost effectiveness standard
work if they can't
compare the cost
effectiveness of [INAUDIBLE]?
NEEMA NASSIR: My
sense is that it
has to be in a modus
specific, but yeah,
but I can take that and--
Yeah.
It makes more sense to be, yeah,
because you probably cannot
compare the effectiveness of
a bus versus a train in terms
of operating costs
at least, right?
So this is the standard
process of decision
making when it comes to new
projects and new proposals,
service proposals, and changes
to the existing service
in Toronto Transit Commission.
This gives you an overview
of different tasks
that are basically done to
start with a set of proposals
and to make the decision on
which ones to be implemented
and so on and so forth.
So if you look at the
column on the right,
it basically includes
the decision--
it deals mostly with
the decision making
on the new service proposals.
First, you get some
requests from municipalities
and some suggestions
from the staff
about new service proposals.
Then, if these proposals are
passing your system guidelines,
then there would be
two possibilities.
If they are minor costs, they'd
go directly to recommendation.
And if they are
major costs, then you
need to do a benefit
cost analysis,
and that basically
includes estimation
of ridership and estimation
of costs and benefits.
And then, once you have a better
sense of benefits and costs
and benefit/cost
measures of the project,
then there will be a
comparative evaluation
of alternative designs
and alternative proposals.
At this stage, there
will be another input
from changes to the
existing system that
comes into the comparative
evaluation, which we will
get to that branch in a minute.
After these projects get to
the recommendation level,
the staff makes a
recommendation to the board,
and then there will be
a review and decision
about acceptance or rejections
of some of these proposals.
And then there will
be an implementation
of the successful proposals.
And then there will
be a probationary time
to implement the successful
proposals and then to,
after six months, it will get
back to the recommender team
to see if it would pass
the probationary period.
On the other hand,
there is a set
of proposals that are made to
make changes to the existing
service and that basically
comes from two main streams--
one is a continuous monitoring
of ridership and loads
and the other one is the
annual route efficiency review.
And from this, then
the staff actually
identify service changes
and assess the impacts
on passengers.
If the impacts are
minor, it goes directly
and it becomes implemented.
If impacts are major,
then these changes
become into a form of
a proposal and comes
to the stream of
comparative analysis
that would be actually compared
with new service proposals
and follow the same
procedure with that.
OK.
Any questions about this?
We'll actually get to
the main two streams
on changes to the
existing service
in the second next
slide right now.
So the first slide is
dealing with basically
the continuous
monitoring of the system
that Transit Authority
or transit agency staff
regularly do.
It's basically, the input
into this kind of process
involves ridership counts,
regular ridership counts,
customer communication,
customer complaint records,
some observations
from staff in terms
of the performance
of these routes
and for possible
adjustments that
could be done and then
from operations report.
Then there will be a comparison
of ridership to load standards.
What we basically
discussed last week
in terms of level of
service measures related
to maximum load will actually
be tested for all the routes.
And then depending
on the situation,
if there is available vehicles
and budgets, then the staff
actually making their
recommendations of changing
the service, if there is
availability of vehicle
and budget, there will be
improvement in the service
and increase in
the service level.
And then it will be reviewed for
recommendation, staff approval,
and implementation, and this is
a closed loop that is usually
done on a regular basis.
Then there is another
process related
to the existing
service that deals
with yearly review of the routes
in terms of route efficiency
review.
And basically, you kind
of consider a route
from a cost and
benefit perspective.
And on the left, you can see new
riding counts or yearly riding
counts that's actually are
collected from the study year.
And then that goes
complemented with the record
of complaints and
customer satisfaction
reports and service regularity.
And it will be combined with
the financial performance
and basically the
measure of costs
that are spent to each route.
And then it comes to this
joint here with reviewing
the structure of the route.
Some of these
routes may be routes
with branches which actually
makes the analysis a little bit
more difficult,
especially design
of branching and alignment
of branching, making sure
that the frequency and the
load profiles and maximum loads
are actually satisfying
the standards
before and after the joints.
Because as you may have
already thought about,
some of-- so, for example,
say Green Line here in Boston,
in the part that is--
for example, where
you have higher demand
in the central area, one
of the effective techniques
in design of routes is to
join some of these routes
into one service to avoid
additional transfers
and to produce connectivity
to the central area
without need of a transfer here.
However what it
actually causes is
that the demand that you're
collecting from lower density
suburbs are basically based
on given frequencies here.
And you set these frequency
based on these demands.
But when it comes
to the merge points,
the frequency will be
the combined frequency
and the demand, kind
of crowded situation
will be the combined situation.
So you need to make sure that
all these standards and all
the guidelines are holding
for all these branches
at the same time.
OK.
And then after that, let me try
to clarify this a little bit.
For example, considering the--
similar to the
example that we made
last week related to two
suburbs that are actually
using the transit service.
So let's say suburb one, suburb
two, and this is downtown area.
If the existing service is a
direct line between suburb one
to destination and
passengers from suburb two
basically walk to this
stop to get to destination,
then assume that the
new proposal of service
is basically adding one
detour here to serve this.
Try to clarify
this a little bit.
For example, considering
similar to the example
that we made last week
related to two suburbs that
are actually using the
transit service in the--
so let's say suburb one, suburb
two, and this is downtown area.
If the existing service is a
direct line between suburb one
to destination and
passengers from suburb two
basically walk to this
stop to get to destination,
then assume that the
new proposal of service
is basically adding one detour
here to serve this suburb
two on the way to destination,
then what needs to be done
is that we need to make sure
that the total generalized cost
that is computed for all
the passengers from suburb
one and suburb
two to destination
would be reduced after the
introduction of this detour.
And then how do we compute
the total generalized cost
that is experienced
by the passengers?
There are some equivalent
values that are usually used.
For example, for every
vehicle travel time,
you assume, one in
vehicle travel minute.
And then for every
minute of waiting time,
you assume 1.5 or so.
For every minute of walking
time that is required,
you consider two minutes
of in-vehicle time.
That's the case
for, for example,
when you want to measure the
cost of walking from this area
to the stop.
And then the cost
of each transfer
is considered to be 10 minutes,
equivalent to 10 minutes.
Is there any
questions about this?
AUDIENCE: So from the local
suburb [INAUDIBLE] so in case
there would be
[INAUDIBLE] However,
it may just be the
fact that [INAUDIBLE]..
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
If the service can
attract latent demand--
so the question was that
this condition does not
account for latent
demand, and it kind of
assumes that the demand is
constant between the two
scenarios.
So my impression
is that whenever
there is latent demand,
that could actually
be considered an advantage.
So you can safely assume with
the existing level of demand
if this change or if
this new service can
reduce the total system cost?
But I do not know
how they exactly
implement this when it
comes to demand prediction.
OK.
So any other
questions about this?
You may ask where does
these numbers come from?
I mean, these coefficients, how
do we get these coefficients?
They may make sense.
At least, to me,
actually, they're
kind of consistent with the way
I perceive the cost of travel
in different components
of trips, in vehicle time,
waiting time.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Why is the
transfer worth more than 10?
NEEMA NASSIR: That's
10 minutes considered
for one required transfer.
So for example,
that's the case where
you have direct access
between origin and destination
versus where you need to make
at least one transfer to get
to destination.
So the way these coefficients
are quantified or understood
is that if you
look at the choices
people make in terms of
paths that they choose,
given their available
path alternatives,
and you can basically calibrate
these coefficients based
on the assumption
that passengers
try to maximize their
utility or minimize
their generalized cost.
There is techniques involving
the theory of utility
maximization that
is usually used
in practice to look at
the actual observed path
choices the
passengers are making
and quantify these coefficients.
AUDIENCE: So what
if you maximize--
I mean, for that to result in
benefit for customers overall,
you would have to
increase, for example,
like headways or frequencies
from part of the trip,
but then go back to
previous frequency levels?
NEEMA NASSIR: You
mean, in the merging?
AUDIENCE: Here, as
part of the transfers.
It's only way to maximize
the benefit for customers.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
So the scenario that I
tried to explain here
was removing this
route and adding
this layout for the
route and replacing it
with this alternative.
So you can keep the same
frequency before and after
and the waiting time
could be kind of the same.
Or you can alternatively
add additional routes
and improve the frequency
for other parts of the system
but make sure that
you're serving the demand
on the distant suburb.
AUDIENCE: How do you
compensate the path right here?
NEEMA NASSIR: This one, right?
This part?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because they're
traveling a longer route.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah.
They basically-- the in-vehicle
time for these people
will be increased.
So this is the
measure like the--
after you implement this change,
if you want to and analyze
the scenario, the in-vehicle
time for traveling from--
it's usually IVT for S1 to
D for after will be greater
than IVT for S1 to D, right?
So in-vehicle time
will be increased.
However, what's going
to change for passengers
who are traveling from S2
to D, the walking distance
is going to decrease, which
has a coefficient of two.
The in-vehicle time
may increase somehow
because they are boarding
now at this point,
but depending on what
frequencies you're designing,
you can compute the waiting time
and put that into consideration
and into computations.
So how are we doing on time?
OK.
So Toronto financial
standards and comparisons--
basically, service
change proposals
are evaluated according to
customers gained or lost
per dollar spent or saved.
Again, the benefit that
is imagined for transit
is in terms of the
number of customers,
the number of passengers
that are added and are
using and benefiting
from the service.
And the cost side is
basically the net cost,
like the operating
cost minus the revenue.
And Toronto applies this
for new service proposals
and possible reduction to the
service and to fare changes.
Again, the financial
unit actually
that goes into
these computations
is the net cost, operating
cost minus the revenue.
And the threshold that
is used by Toronto
is 0.23 as the
standard threshold,
that's 0.23 passengers
per dollar spent.
So for each dollar
that you're spending
on the operation
minus the revenue,
you need to guarantee at least
point 0.23 passengers are
basically getting served.
AUDIENCE: That's operating
dollars and passengers.
It's not a capital expense.
It's operating.
NEEMA NASSIR: It's operating.
Yeah, I think it's operating
cost minus the revenue,
probably, right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
And then services that are
operating below this level,
we actually get kind of reviewed
in the annual yearly review
process.
Again, in terms of
service change process,
major service changes are
evaluated twice per year.
They're basically ranked
in the comparative analysis
and based on their performance
and based on productivity
of the existing service.
There is a board in
the Transit Agency
that makes these decisions.
Usually, they invite people
from metropolitan transportation
planning agencies too or higher
level governmental agencies.
So these boards basically
review the recommendations
from the staff
and make decisions
based on their merits.
The guiding principles
for TransLink
for Vancouver in service
optimization program,
is to maintain basic service
for transit-dependent customers,
like what we discussed
about the existing service
and how passengers may
actually be dependent.
And we need to be
careful when we
want to remove some of
the existing service
and maintain service that
are strategic for network
connectivity.
Sometimes it becomes
a little tricky
when we look at the routes
individually and do not
consider their role
and their functionality
in the performance
at the network level.
So the guiding
principles of TransLink
kind of enforce
this concentration.
And then minimize service
reductions in area
with no transit alternatives,
supporting growing market
where productivity is
improving, reinvest in service
to generate higher
revenue ridership,
and reinvest in service that
supports long-term goals
and objectives of TransLink.
So let's open a discussion
now for a few minutes in terms
of possible critiques
and possible caveats
of the existing practice
for short-range planning.
Let's start-- does anyone have
any comments or any thoughts
about the existing
caveats or critiques yet?
AUDIENCE: Slide 36.
NEEMA NASSIR: Yeah,
it is actually.
AUDIENCE: Where it says the TTC
value is, the financial impact
of service changes.
Any service change
proposal is evaluated
according to customers gained or
lost per dollar spent or saved.
Does not mean that
they could eliminate
any stops, for example,
and not lose any customers?
They'd just make those
customers walk further
and make service less
convenient for them,
that that would be a
sound decision according
to these criteria?
NEEMA NASSIR: So yeah.
So do you mean, if you're
making some changes that reduces
the actual number of customers--
AUDIENCE: Say they make a change
and they don't lose customers
but service is
worse for customers.
The customers have
no other options,
so they continue using
the service, even
thought it's slightly worse.
NEEMA NASSIR: So yeah,
that's a good point.
That's a good point.
So probably the
important caveats
is that many of these
guidelines and standards
are not from the
passenger's perspective.
So passenger's perspective
performance measures
and passenger's
perspective perceptions
of the quality of
service is something
that probably should
be incorporated
in some of these measures.
AUDIENCE: Isn't it some of the
checks and balances in place
because it's relatively
easy in services
neutral users of these
services lean on it
and some people have
to walk further.
So that in itself would lead
to a reduction in the number
of people who take the route.
So for example, from suburb
S1, the number of people
who [INAUDIBLE] So analysis
at route level, because then
it might actually go
in favor of the agency.
NEEMA NASSIR: So exactly.
So analysis at the
network level should
be something that
probably better captured
by these guidelines.
And one of the other things that
is not actually included here
is the actual objective
of transit agency, which
is improvement and increase
of the ridership, which
is not explicitly tied to any
of the existing guidelines.
That's something that could
be identified thinking of it
as an optimization problem as
an optimal or objective function
to be optimized over the
solution of space, which
is the guidelines,
existing guidelines
and standards in the service.
So what this guideline
that we discussed
here is just the bound
on what is acceptable
and what's not acceptable.
But the fact that is this going
to be beneficial to the system
or not?
That's something that requires
better analysis of the plan
basically.
So any others?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Comment
on just one thing.
Is this less for the short
term service planning
and the problem with
short-term planning
often a lot of the
demand and [INAUDIBLE]
will be contemplate.
Whenever you do major
additions, extensions,
or you have a
major budget crisis
and it's a cut off
service, that would not
be considered entirely
a short-term thing
but more of a bigger impact.
So the study would be
required with demand more.
NEEMA NASSIR: Correct.
Exactly.
OK so in the last slide there
is a list of possible caveats
that are mentioned here.
Couple of those we
already discussed.
Focus of the existing practice
is on poorly-performing routes,
whereas it does not
necessarily have
to be a poorly-performing
route that has the potential
to be improved to improve the
performance of the system.
There is data limitation
both on type and quality.
We observed that in
many of the measurements
and in many of the
decision making,
there is lots of
uncertainty that
is related to quality of
data and limitations of data.
So hopefully, with
the new generations
of passively-collected data
that are nowadays introduced,
there will be improvement
in the existing practice
to take advantage of that
data and improve the planning
process.
Again, measures not always
closely tied to objectives.
That's something that
is relevant to what
Adishak mentioned in terms
of some of these measures
are basically just
constraints and lower bound
and they're not necessarily
tied to the objective, which
is improvement of mobility
and improvement, increase
of ridership.
And then focus on
individual routes
may actually not be
ideal because kind of it
ignores the network level
functionality of routes.
So any questions about this?
Any additional
comments in terms of--
right.
OK.
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: So the idea of
utility is not always something
that someone actually
calculates for when
they're considering
these simulations
or calculations or changes.
It's kind of theoretical.
If we do this then
it will affect us
but there isn't necessarily
a quantitative way.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
The utility itself is a random
and unknown quantity, right?
There's a random
component to it.
But the marginal
rate of substitutions
of these coefficients related
to different components,
that's something that
can be quantified.
For example, what
is the disutility
of waiting time as
compared to the disutility
of in-vehicle time.
So that's a way kind of have a
sense of the generalized cost.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you
also use a dollar proxy
to say that the economy is
stimulated in x, y, and z?
Is that another way
of looking at it?
NEEMA NASSIR: I think the--
yeah, I'm not sure about--
AUDIENCE: It's typically
used for capital investments.
All these people
that are looking
for short-term funds, things
like environmental impacts
and economic welfare at a large
scale are equally the methods.
You are considering a
minor extension or increase
in service with
the same alignment.
So you're probably not going
to do a fully [INAUDIBLE]
gradual marginal change.
But in a bigger context
then, yes, you would have,
a four-step model and
you would look at CO2
and look at many other things.
And one example of that
would be the recent example
of London Crossrail, where
a lot of the business
case for Crossrail had to do
with deliberation and things
like this, not necessarily the
time that people were saving.
AUDIENCE: When we say
poorly-performing routes,
are we talking only in terms
of timing, for example,
or are we also talking
about poorly-performing
in terms of financial
return of the route?
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
Right.
AUDIENCE: I'm afraid that
for example, if people
talk about financially,
certain routes might get closed
for low demand, and then
you have the equity problem
that we talked about over there.
NEEMA NASSIR: Right.
Yeah.
So I believe when
you're evaluating
the quality of
these routes, we can
use all the existing
criteria that we mentioned.
For example, the criteria
that is related to access,
the criteria that is related
to span of the service, access
over time and space,
and then measures
that are dealing with the
productivity of the route
and the financial aspects.
So my guess is that
this is probably
kind of when we're
evaluating the routes,
we are taking into
account the equity issue
and the access issue and all
those sorts of guidelines
that we discussed last
week into consideration.